[Musique]
on a tous rêvé de partir en reportage
c'est la figure de tintin reporter c'est
la grande photographe gerda taro
c'est robert capa c'est aussi la légende
henri cartier bresson
ce sont tous ces photographes qui m'ont
inspiré être photographe documentaire ce
n'est pas un métier c'est un mode de vie
et ce mode de vie pour moi il a commencé
très tôt quand j'étais enfant j'ai eu la
chance de grandir dans une galerie
peinture est tout petit je griffonnais
déjà sur des bouts de toiles de roger
sommes ville
à 12 ans j'ai reçu mon premier appareil
photo et puis adolescent ce fut la
découverte du cinéma avec mon père dans
le petit cinéma du forum à salzinnes où
nous allions voir le goût de la papaye
verte languit épouses et concubines
c'était tout des références qui se sont
inscrits en moins après il ya eu les
études une maîtrise en histoire une
maîtrise en philosophie et puis toujours
l'anthropologie qui était une partenaire
silencieuse mais bien présent dans mon
parcours
après ses études il est humain
assistanat l'université de namur avec un
semestre si l université de kyoto mais à
la fin de ce parcours je dois vous
l'avouer je ressentais comme un an qu il
me manquait les couleurs il me manquait
les traits il me manquait les contrastes
il me manquait la lumière et puis
surtout il me manquait une certaine
forme de travail de terrain être
photographe documentaire ce n'est pas
que faire de l'image c'est avant tout
être sur les terrains c'est vivre avec
les gens dormir comme manger comme se
déplaçait comme c'est adopter de manière
passagère un mode de vie qui n'est pas
le mien mais qui est le leur dans mon
travail j'essaie toujours de combiner
une démarche plus intellectuel plus
intelligent avec une démarche beaucoup
plus intuitive plus instinctive avec de
l'émotion
je suis ce qu'on appelle un photographe
du doute et je doute de tout en
reportage a démarré à commencer par moi
même mes propres images mon travail mais
ce doute est un moteur ce vide est un
moteur il me permet de questionner ce
que je fais et surtout d'essayer
d'éclairer d'autres modes de vie des
modes de vie qui il faut bien l'admettre
sont affaiblis sont tannés atténuer sont
parfois déconstruit ou encore détruit
par une certaine mondialisation et la
globalisation nous partageons tous la
même condition humaine ça me semble
évident mais nous ne vivons pas dans les
mêmes conditions et c'est souvent là
qu'apparaît devant l'objectif les
injustices et de très sérieuse remise en
question
elle s'appelle tanner kawa elle a 19 ans
elle vit à kyoto c'est une apprentie
geisha une maiko le monde des geishas ce
n'est pas ce qu'on croit nous y
projetons volontiers beaucoup de
fantasmes
mais ce sont des femmes artistes elle
joue de la musique elle effectue la
cérémonie du thé elle danse elle
participe à des rituels leur quotidien
c'est un parcours initiatique pendant
quelques années elles vont essayer de
devenir un idéal type féminin cet idéal
elle le puise dans différentes
traditions le chamanisme le théâtre du
kabuki l'art courtois la peinture la
littérature japonaise et cet idéal type
va leur permettre de représenter une
autre féminité tanner kawa son quotidien
est très difficile
elle se lève tôt elle fini très tard
c'est beaucoup de répétitions c'est une
vraie volonté les hommes et les femmes
qui fréquentent les maisons de thé c'est
à dire qu'ils fréquentent le monde des
geishas ne viennent pas pour fantasmer
ils ne viennent pas pour s'amuser quand
vous parlez avec eux ils vous diront
nous venons voir un exemple même
d'esprit d'indépendance
parce que tu as n'est qu'à voir très
jeune
à 16 ans a décidé de devenir geisha et
s'est choisi une vie avant que la
société japonaise ne le choisisse une
vie à la question c'est quoi être une
femme au 21ème siècle au japon
chaque jour tanner kawa apporte une
réponse différente une réponse originale
c'est en quelque sorte un acte de
résistance par rapport à d'autres
modèles de féminité odudu rama est une
grand mère merveilleuse du népal elle
vit dans la banlieue nord de katmandou
elle élève ses petits enfants elle a
survécu au tremblement de terre de
gorkha en avril 2015
le népal subi un cynisme terrible il y à
9000 morts il y avait en 2000 blessés
et ça paraît bien dérisoire ac étaient
tous là mais 50 % du pib et disparaît
depuis le pays essaye de se reconstruire
essaye de se refaire des maisons de
l'habitat et tout ce qui constitue un
quotidien dans le drame que d'uramin a
vécu elle a vécu avec une vache elle
possède une vache et lui parle
régulièrement comment une rescapée ce
qu'elle me disait souvent c'est ce
silence de mort dans le nuage de
poussière qu'il y avait juste après la
secousse
son quotidien c'est des revenus très
faibles beaucoup de népalais doivent
partir au qatar pour espérer avoir
suffisamment que pour élever leurs
enfants
reconstruire leurs maisons ce dont elle
me parle c'est l'heure les conditions de
vie l'accès à l'électricité qui est très
problématique
l'accès à l'eau qui l'est encore plus et
puis enfin la scolarité et moi dans tout
ça qui comme beaucoup de photographes
dès qu'il y ait un désastre quelque part
on est en général assez rapide à aller
sur place faire de la photo mais qu'est
ce qu'on fait à ce moment là depuis quel
point de vue je viens moi regarder le
fracas du monde depuis quel point de vue
je viens poser mon appareil
c'est une question terrible pour nous
photographe et c'est une vraie question
raksha est une éleveurs mongols elle vit
dans la vallée du serpent noir et la 34
ans c'est une grande plaine qui est
entouré de collines et de loups son
quotidien comme vous le voyez c'est la
traite de ses 180 yak n'est quelques
juments et des moutons et les chèvres
qu'il possède dans cette partie de la
mongolie nous sommes dans la province de
berkane gaye la vie évidemment est très
difficile la mongolie c'est un des
derniers exemples au monde de
pastoralisme semi nomades et la mongolie
subit aussi les effets du réchauffement
climatique
au travers de ce qu'on nomme les houde
les août ce sont des épisodes de très
grand froid mais avec une un son une
intensité qu'on ne connaissait pas
jusqu'à lors
quand vous parlez avec odorama avec
raksha pardon elle vous dira que son
plus grand souci c'est pas tellement le
travail dans la steppe c'est pas la
rudesse mais c'est la scolarité c'est
l'accès à la scolarité pour ses deux
enfants
en effet pendant les mois d'été elle est
là avec son époux galles badra mais
pendant les mois d'hiver elle doit aller
en ville en ville elle doit dépenser
beaucoup d'argent en ville tout s'achète
rien ne s'échangent en ville elle met
ses enfants à l'école mais en ville et
les seuls son mari reste avec les bêtes
pendant tout l'hiver
c'est une séparation qui leur coûtent
beaucoup d'être comme ça dans deux
endroits très différents en mongolie on
mange beaucoup de jaune ça c'est une
évidence mais par contre c'est un
cannibalisme bienveillant qui est en
train d'avaler leur mode de vie
ce cannibalisme bienveillant il apparaît
en 1990 est tout simplement c'est
l'économie de marché la mongolie va
quitter le communisme va rentrer dans le
libéralisme dans l'économie de marché
avec deux voisins un peu lourd dans tous
les sens du terme
la chine la russie
et peu à peu on se rend compte que les
éleveurs sont poussés dans le dos par
une sorte de contrainte aveugle une main
invisible à abandonner leur mode de vie
ce qu'elle vous dira quand vous lui
posez la question de de son bonheur elle
vous dira c'est difficile comment est-ce
qu'on peut encore continuer comment
peut-on encore être libre de choisir ou
pas ce mode de vie susan est une
réfugiée zidi elle vit dans le nord de
l'irak dans un camp qui se trouve non
loin de la ville 2 à 8 ans et la 14 ans
comme beaucoup de réfugiés y dit elle a
vécu l'enfer
et quand vous interrogez les survivants
de ce camp ils vous diront quand on les
a kidnappé
c'est comme si on nous a arraché le
coeur en effet en juillet 2015
les soldats de dash vont s'attaquer à la
ville de sinjar la ville de sinjar est
essentiellement habité par les yézidis
la ville ainsi que tous les villages
vont être vidés de leurs habitants
les hommes vont être systématiquement
massacrés les bébés aussi les femmes
vont être capturé suzanne a vu tout ça
beaucoup de femmes pour éviter d'être
prise par les soldats de dash et la
barbarie s'ouvriront les veines devant
elle son parcours après c'est la prison
de badouche et puis transféré à tal afar
et puis transféré dans la ville de
mossoul à mossoul nous savons tous
qu'elle a été libérée il ya eu les
bombardements et les lourdement blessé
elle profite justement de ces
bombardements pour s'échapper et c'est
grâce aux réseaux sociaux
on va pouvoir la recontre connecter avec
sa famille quand elle retrouve ses
proches
quand elle retrouve les siens
en juillet 2010 est elle ne sait plus
parler que peut-on dire après ça le
moyen-orient et ses enjeux le
moyen-orient et ses enjeux et la vie de
susan
que fait-on avec ça alors c'est vrai que
nous ici en europe
nous faisons beaucoup de choses nous
faisons beaucoup aussi
mais en quittant le camp de zawit à elle
m'a dit mais que faites-vous vraiment en
europe avec la guerre ici est la raison
que fait on qu'est ce que je fais que
fait-on ou plutôt que ne ferions nous
pas pour continuer pour maintenir
intactes pour maintenir confortable un
certain mode de vie
photo n'essaye pas d'illustrer le réel
elle essaie chacune de le penser elle
essaye de le comprendre
elle tente de vous le faire voir de
réaliser quelque chose qui pour beaucoup
d'entre nous et je ne suis pas différent
de vous et distant est abstrait c'est un
travail de proximité
je pense que le plus grand monstre du
21e siècle
ce n'est pas tant la mondialisation et
la globalisation mais c'est plutôt
l'ethnocentrisme et l'ethnocentrisme
occidental ne pas le voir c'est le
laisser agir
nous sommes nombreux dans le monde du
photojournalisme à penser qu'il y ait un
vrai devoir de regard mais il ya aussi
un devoir de résistance une résistance
face à l'indifférence face à la
supercherie farce à l'absurdité
si la mondialisation et la globalisation
peuvent avoir un sens et je pense qu'on
peut en trouver un il doit être
solidaire il doit être partagé par tous
ici là-bas chez nous chez eux
c'est le sens que j'essaye donner à
chacun de mes reportages
c'est aussi mon mode de vie merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]